この章では、
量子コンピューターと古典コンピューターが
協力して科学における最も重要な課題の一つを解く方法を探ります。
それは、分子や材料のエネルギーを正確に推定することです。
この問題を解決するために、
量子circuitを使って
基底状態のサンプルを生成し、
それを後処理して
このアルゴリズム群の固有値を対角化します。
このアルゴリズムファミリーには
SQVやSKGなどがあり、IBMの
量子プラットフォームには
これらおよび関連手法を専門に扱う
コース全体が用意されています。本章では
説明を簡潔にまとめます。
SQVを使う場合もSKGを使う場合も、
目標はハミルトニアン行列の
固有ベクトルと固有値を求めることです。
この行列は物理系や
化学系のエネルギーを表すことがありますが、同じ枠組みで
他の多くの問題タイプにも対応できます。
例えばロジスティクスなどです。
これらの行列は非常に大きい場合があります。
そのため、次元を削減しながら
行列の重要な特徴を保持することが、
基底状態の観点から
非常に価値を持ちます。それがSQVの目標です。
量子コンピューターを使って有用な部分空間、
つまり基底状態を含む空間を生成します。
その後、ハミルトニアン行列を
その部分空間に射影することで、
小さな行列が得られます。この行列は
対角化がずっと容易です。
古典的な高性能コンピューティングを用いてこれを行います。そのために
試行量子状態、
いわゆるアンザッツを準備し、
そのアンザッツをサンプリングするための測定を行います。
計算基底で測定することで、
計算基底上のサンプル部分空間が得られます。
しかし、本当に求めているのは
真の基底状態です。
もしサンプルした部分空間に
必要な成分がすべて含まれていなかったら
どうすればいいでしょうか？より良いアンザッツを選べば、
基底状態のより良い推定が得られるかもしれません。
それが、サンプルベースの
量子対角化、すなわちSKDにつながります。SKDでは
同様にアンザッツから始めますが、
さらに物理系の時間発展を近似するquantum gateを適用します。
これにより物理系の時間発展が近似されます。
いくつかの仮定のもとで、
時間発展したアンザッツと真の基底状態との重なりに
保証が得られることが示されています。
これらのアルゴリズムはどちらも巨大な
ハミルトニアン行列を出発点とし、やや異なる動作をしますが、
いずれの場合もアルゴリズムの量子部分が
行列を縮小できる部分空間を生成します。
そこで基底状態の重要な特徴が保持されることを期待します。
では、高性能古典コンピューティングはどこで
役割を果たすのでしょうか？最も大きなハミルトニアンに対して
基底状態の最も正確な推定を求める場合、
射影後の行列でもかなり大きくなることがあります。
そのため、より強力な古典コンピューターの能力を活用することで
結果を向上させるだけでなく、
より良い結果を得るだけでなく、
より大きな問題にも取り組めるようになります。
全体をまとめると、
サンプルベースのアルゴリズムは
異なるプログラミングモデルの組み合わせとして
ヘテロジニアスなリソース上で表現できます。
例えば、アルゴリズムを
タスクワークフローとして表現できます。まず
ターゲット状態と重なる量子circuitを準備するタスク、
そして目標状態に重なるようにする、その後に
古典リソースのみで実行できるtranspilerのタスクが続きます。
次に実行されるのは
プリミティブを使って量子circuitを実行するタスクです。
これは当然ながら
量子リソースを必要とします。そして後処理タスクがあり、それ自体が
並列対角化アルゴリズムとして
複数のノードで実行される場合があります。
さらに、これらのアルゴリズムを
何度も繰り返し実行したい場合もあります。
アンザッツを変えながら実行したり、
あるいはまったく並列に
異なるパラメーターで実行することもできます。
では、SKDをまとめて
コードで確認してみましょう。タスクファイルがすべて揃っています。
そしてこちらがすべてのサブミッションファイルです。
マッピングタスクではcircuitを準備します。
最適化ステップでは、circuitを最適な方法で実行します。
実行タスクでは、
準備された状態から
ISA circuitによってビット列をサンプリングします。
前のステップの出力を受け取り、
後処理を行います。
これで、
ワークフローをサブミットする準備が整いました。
ご覧の通り、すべてが依存関係のある
順序で実行されます。結果を待ちながら
出力ファイルを確認してみましょう。
こちらが最適化ステップの出力ファイルで、
ISA circuitが含まれています。
最後に、固有値分解の
結果を確認してみましょう。
スケジュールから確認できます。
SKDワークフローの簡単なデモはここまでです。
すべてのコードはテキストセクション
または説明欄からご覧いただけます。
これで、複雑なハイブリッドプログラムの管理に
役立つ概念と例をいくつか紹介しました。
もちろん、これは量子と古典リソースを組み合わせて
できることの表面をなぞっているに過ぎません。
量子と古典の両方のリソースを組み合わせて
できることをさらに探求するには、
IBMの量子プラットフォームにある
ドキュメントやチュートリアルをご覧ください。
またテキストセクションや説明欄で共有されている
リソースもぜひご確認ください。
ご視聴ありがとうございました。
はい、以上です。